okay so last week was pretty hype
but that's last week it's in the past
this week we're turning things up a
notch as we springboard off the back of
the 21st tenkaichi budokai and
into the sprawling and powerful arcs
covered today something i hope will be
apparent in this particular video is the
slow progression toriyama takes in not
only creating and expanding his world
but also the rogues gallery of villains
that populate this increasingly wondrous
and dangerous landscape
too in this installment of my dragon
ball review i'm taking a look at a
particularly notorious group
responsible for horrors even those
having only seen dragon ball z might
remember
i am of course talking about sun goku's
first clash with
the infamous red ribbon army
[Music]
[Applause]
this is gonna be a big one guys so let's
not delay
i'm totally not mark and this is my
review of akira toriyama's underrated
and undefeated
dragon ball
[Music]
[Applause]
my biggest nitpick concerning the modern
dragon ball super anime for those of you
that haven't seen that review series i
made over a year ago
has to be its sudden and abrupt cold
openings to new arcs
when the battle of god's arc ends it
ends and then a completely new story
disconnected from the prime material
would be getting you and
the same is true for universe 6 and goku
black and so forth and all of these feel
like self-contained stories not
necessarily connected in any meaningful
way
narratively to the prior this doesn't
bother everyone but to me it misses a
mark the original dragon ball and
z would always hit for instance off the
back of the 21st tenkaichi budokai that
i covered last week there's some nice
lighthearted humor with goku pretty much
eating all the prize money's worth of
food
courtesy of roshi himself but what i
like most about this scene
was its immediate redirection of her
attention towards a new goal
a goal that will inform the direction
for the next arc the retrieval of
grandpa gohan's four-star
dragon ball the red ribbon army saga
as has been the case since the beginning
of this story thus far moving forward
there will continue to be a pervasive
and strong comedic energy throughout the
upcoming material however what i want to
draw your attention to before we get
into the story proper
is as it progresses i'd like for you
guys to pay attention to
the slowly escalating sense of drama and
stakes i asked this not because there
will necessarily be noticeable stakes in
this video i mean there very well might
be lord knows i'm not going to spoil you
but this
escalation in mood stakes and drama will
undoubtedly manifest in some impressive
and game-changing ways later and so as
we race forward into this brave new
world in search of goku's four-star
dragon ball i think you should keep in
mind where we started in the last video
and appreciate the growth as it becomes
more and more distinct
slowly becoming the story we're familiar
with in zee
so goku swung across the sky when he's
suddenly shot down by a missile launcher
i repeat goku and kyduan are both blown
out of the sky
by a missile launcher everyone this is
the first contact goku makes with the
antagonists of this arc
through one colonel silver he has
unknowingly and single-handedly created
an enemy that will become more powerful
than he or anyone else in this world
could possibly imagine
in this story goku challenges the most
powerful evil organization in the world
the red ribbon army
[Music]
also in search of the dragon balls
speaking to the driving forces of this
narrative something i thought was great
was how goku's friendship
with bulma was the reason he's able to
hone in on these dragon balls much
faster and more effectively than the red
ribbon army can
organically it creates the necessary
tension to bring them into contact and
without words communicates why they are
in conflict it's a wonderful mechanism
in this regard that's quite believable
muscle tower while this red ribbon army
arc is the longest of any we've covered
thus far
dealing with three commanding officers
increasing in importance as we go
through the three acts of the story in
this opening act we're kicking things
off with general white and his fortress
shrouded in treacherous icy tundra
this is a terrific example again of
akira toriyama's desire to create an
interesting but easy to understand place
to take full advantage of his audience's
anticipation and his ability to draw
well in 3d space if his audience can
understand the space in a
three-dimensional sense then he can do
much more with the action
[Music]
when i first read through this years ago
something i didn't fully appreciate was
how
nice it was that we got some time to
spend with goku one-on-one as a
character
alone i was honestly pretty surprised it
took so long for something like this to
happen
oh and by the way this opening arc which
effectively acts as an empowerment to
the audience and goku as they cut
through the red ribbon army like butter
watching as he obliterates his way
through general white's defenses floor
after floor is again
very fun but this section is also
reinforcing goku's character as someone
that will want to do the right thing
for those that did right by him
protecting the defenseless village
against the red ribbon army who are
looking to get the dragon ball in the
area
and radar into their possession in other
words goku is protecting those that need
his protection hearkening back to the
last ark's philosophy and
i loved it furthermore the framing of
these encounters is sort of gamified or
fun for lack of a better term the goal
is to get to the top of the tower
reprimand general white and save the
town's mayor from capture with every
floor introducing more and more intense
conflicts going from grunts on the
ground floor to the conflict with full
metal jacket on the third the first
robotic foe
goku has faced in the series definitely
a trend of things to come
this fight against full metal jacket is
actually sort of suspenseful mostly
because it provides a strong contrast
with the initial floors and
confrontations between goku
and the earlier portion of the red
ribbon army with colonel silver not
putting up much of a fight at all with
this fight totally taking goku and his
new extensive powers totally by surprise
as the mechanical monstrosity
relentlessly pushes goku more than any
fight he's encountered since roshi
the fourth floor fight against sergeant
major purple the ninja is
very comedy focused the purple fight
consists of
at first a game of hide-and-seek with
goku foiling his concealment strategies
at every conceivable turn in
increasingly ridiculous fashion overall
compared to the prior bow this encounter
acts as another opportunity for goku to
flex how much more powerful he is
than a cocky opponent it's tonally
completely different to the full metal
jacket fight leaning perhaps
more than any other fight into the more
comedic gag
format and i say that while also being
fully aware that earlier goku sent a
humanoid gangster rabbit to the moon
on an extendable pole
as soon as android 8 shows his face he
immediately contrasted himself with full
metal jacket
and i fell in love with his character
for that he's so ominous and domineering
physically but
totally harmless personally which is in
and of itself another nice contrast to
oppose goku's small but impossibly
strong persona
only on this second read through am i
noticing all of these contrast toriyama
has implemented here i also love the
role that android 8 plays in helping
goku overcome this ninja man in addition
to helping goku navigate the mazes that
comprise the upper levels of muscle
tower
i like it because it ultimately means
that goku manages to escape this tower
and reach where he wants to go
because of him being a decent person
deep down and for no other reason really
and despite the situation with general
white coming to a close in relatively
quick fashion goku employs some terrific
and clever strategy against the
general's jiggly contingency plan
utilizing information he gleaned from a
young girl earlier towards the beginning
of the arc
demonstrating applied knowledge way to
go goku but again because this is a very
long arc sprawling across
41 chapters akira toriyama decided to
break it up into three easily
identifiable portions
but linked them wonderfully and so with
the muscle tower portion now after
coming to a close we
get our next goal almost immediately off
the back of the last segment
you see during the assault on the tower
goku broke the dragon radar an
understandable and believable
consequence that will drag him back into
contact with the weird and wonderful
girl who started this series with him
[Music]
[Applause]
bulma
i'll only touch on this briefly because
it's only a minor part of the story but
goku arriving in west city in search of
bulma is handled to
absolute perfection knowing goku's
origin and seeing where he
is now in a bustling metropolis it
stands to reason that the very first
time he enters a big city like this it'd
be a fish out of water type scenario and
for some reason
on my first read-through i never
anticipated this running around to
random people asking them where
bulma is was a subtle but brilliant
insight into what goku's expectations
and experiences up until now have been
with him going as far as to remark
huh you live in the same town but you
don't know who she is i
love dialogue like that it really gives
us great insight
into the character's sensibilities and
expectations his search for bulma is
probably the funniest and most endearing
chapter
in the story that i've read thus far
it's full of innocent hijinks with goku
taking center stage trying his best to
understand the social customs of the
area going as far as winning money in
street fights because
he was led to believe money equals
someone telling him where
bulma is and when he learns that cops
can help him the person he asks to find
a cop
gets all that money that he won it's
brilliant it's light
it's over next general blue saga i swear
to god
blue during the pursuit of the next
dragon ball i loved bulma's inclusion
and i thought it was top notch on top of
her being in essence a terrific plot
device that can provide goku with any
help he might need she's also a great
character
full of personality this okay might seem
like a random side note but
one aspect of gt that i didn't like much
was how they used or should i say didn't
use the character of pan
introduced in the opening episode with a
lot of promise i quickly found myself
invested in her budding story and
gravitated towards
the character but it never amounted to
anything she'd always get in the way
needed saving and contributed little if
anything other than complaining or
motivating goku through capture
and while bulma still needs help from
goku goku wouldn't have ever found his
way to this dragon ball beneath the
ocean alone and
that's ignoring the dragon radar she
gave him in the first place goku would
quite literally be lost without her in
this instance
she more than pulls her weight in the
greater story or at least she would if
she didn't accidentally take her dad's
capsules instead
[Music]
and so they reach out to bara roshi's
submarine thing and it's here i noticed
the degree to just how empowering
this arc is during this material goku is
very seldom if ever on the back foot
dominating every encounter with the red
ribbon army's increasingly competent
officials that each without fail commit
the cardinal sin of underestimating our
little hero
one scene in particular that stands out
to me as specifically cathartic in this
regard is the confrontation roshi and
launch experience
on the island with the red ribbon army
themselves the fashion with which
launch and specifically roshi disarmed
the situation and clobber every single
soldier was amazing to read through
further adding value to my dragon ball
experience
i mean if you're from an
english-speaking country odds are your
first introduction to the series was
through dragon ball z
and in that story roshi plays such a
minuscule role you'd be forgiven for
thinking he wasn't anything special at
any point in time but through these
early acts revisiting them helps to
reinforce the type of powerful and
competent character
he actually is what makes this middle
portion of the story so fun at least for
me is how bamboozled and perplexed the
red ribbon army under general blue and
red are they are constantly blown away
by goku's speed moving from one location
to another his ability to locate dragon
balls immediately which they lack the
tech to do
and of course his otherworldly strength
and fighting prowess
and at the moment general blue and his
forces are in pursuit of goku bulma and
krillin as they venture down using
roshi's sub in an underwater cave in
search of the four star ball
now cards on the table here i think of
the three sections i'll be discussing of
the red ribbon army arc this
general blue saga is perhaps the least
interesting i think in large part
because the second act is in large part
difficult to make as interesting in a
story
any story with it primarily serving the
purpose of building up to the events i
am super excited to discuss later on
concerning the
third act with that said however there
are still a lot of aspects to this act
particularly from a human perspective
that i really appreciated general blue
is easily the highlight in terms of
characters presented from the red ribbon
army side of things perhaps throughout
the entire arc itself his ruthless
pursuit of her heroes his merciless and
scary disregard for human life
contrasting beautifully with his
otherwise clean-cut persona carrying
with it a sprinkle of camp humor he's a
bizarre and capable leader and
fighter that places our heroes in
trouble on more than one occasion
speaking of which
[Music]
earlier i mentioned that virtually every
advancement the red ribbon army made on
our heroes resulted in their ultimate
downfall
thus empowering our heroes beyond what
they already were in our minds as
readers or viewers
well that was until general blue finally
started to roll up his sleeves
or take off his shirt whatever you
choose and what i enjoyed about his
clash with krillin wasn't what i saw but
instead
what i didn't see our last checking in
with krillin was during the semi-finals
of the 21st tenkaichi budokai wherein he
demonstrated his martial arts ability
against the eventual winner of the
tournament in jackie chun having
narrowly lost that bout against the
eventual winner
krillin was seen at least to me as close
to goku's level of strength and thus
this was still his standing alongside
the current cast going into the
confrontation with
general blue so keeping in mind the red
ribbon army had effectively been the
punching bag of the heroes up until now
and that krillin is seen as a powerful
fighter akin to goku
you'll maybe get a taste of what sort of
shaka reader would have had in japan
during the time that they turned the
page to see
this we don't see this fight it simply
cuts from before the fight
to after it creating a great contrast
visually but as i drew attention to
earlier
contrasted powerfully with how we
thought things would go too
boastful prideful flamboyant and
downright ruthless
general blue comes out of this encounter
virtually unscathed
and with him mere seconds away from
crushing a paralyzed krillin's skull
with a boulder
the consequences of this meeting really
start to set in and
i love it when toriyama leverages that
aspect of comedy or
the gag comic format to create sudden
and abrupt moments of desperation for
his readers
and i do so because when a character is
moments from a gruesome death
it creates the perfect opportunity for a
moment
like this
this is the first really dramatic save
goku has made that i've recognized
before this in the first arc any save he
would otherwise make would be
accompanied with significant comedic
references
visuals or some combination of the two
however this save is framed as being
entirely dramatic
it's subtle but the development of that
more serious tone ever present in z
is slowly seeping through the pages
gradually even as early as here the
fight itself is
perfectly fine but nothing particularly
interesting outside of that specific
tonal shift i mentioned
effectively the fight continues as many
dragon ball fights do in the early
chapters with some nice paneling
and gag humor to undercut the entire
affair goku overcomes blue he puts a rat
in his mouth and
they geek themselves back to the surface
some more hijinks takes place with
launch in general blue on roshi's island
that is way more funny than it has any
right to be
and then goku starts making his way to a
familiar setting
for some
[Music]
hmm
thanks dude
[Music]
i'm so happy
baby
you're the best dude
where where is she though
jokes aside everyone g field has been
the best sponsor i've worked with in my
career in all honesty the people are
amazing and there's virtually no filter
or script for me to read off of as
made evident by this commercial they
allowed me to make i've tried the
product and i sincerely think it's
delicious so if you'd like to try it for
yourself or want to help out the channel
click the link in the description below
thank you everyone
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
as will become something of a tradition
with toriyama's work he
likes to cameo old characters and not
from the same property but from entirely
different series
now i realize i'm speaking to a minority
when i say this but similar to jaco the
galactic patrol man a manga written
after dragon ball
ended by akira toriyama himself he
decided to make it known that the story
shares the same world as dragon ball did
and similarly to that the final chapters
of the general blue arc
goku and the titular general sort of
stumble into the peculiar penguin
village
fans of his previous dr slot material
will love this segment of the story as
it goes out of its way to bring the
energy of the property to the forefront
perhaps however at the expense of the
newly established dragon ball tone
though
it's a nice call back section with its
own independent high points but i'd be
lying if i thought
it wouldn't have been served better by
sticking to its own property where
jaco's manga benefited i thought from
linking itself to the greater tory verse
i don't think this arc got any more from
this particular interaction in penguin
village with that said
while it was overly light-hearted those
of you that keep tabs on
storytone might anticipate a total shift
soon
for when something good happens in a
story normally
around the next corner is something
likely not too friendly
commander red saga this is the final act
of the red ribbon army arc and while i
did enjoy the prior portions this
upcoming final part is my absolute
favorite and the section i've been
itching to talk about
all video long i love the setting i love
the expanded lore it offers and
above all else i love it for one reason
specifically
now moving at speed towards another
group of red ribbon army soldiers led by
colonel yellow we pick up with oopa and
his father these character designs
clearly take inspiration from native
americans in north america and they're
pretty cool
particularly the father character he's
not overly complicated but he's
courageous righteous and noble and he's
guarding an area called the corn
sanctuary from the incoming red ribbon
army when suddenly
having just saved this young boy goku
finally is reunited with his grandpa's
four-star dragon ball it's a great
moment to finally see this young man
reunited with his prized possession and
all by coming to the rescue of this
group it's a really nice virtuous moment
that yields what he's been searching for
all of this time but just as they're
celebrating a certain assassin is hired
by the red ribbon army
to help recover what they've lost
[Music]
touted as the greatest assassin for hire
in the world is in addition to the
impressive in-universe accolade one of
the most underrated villains in the
entire
dragon ball universe there are a ton of
genuinely impressive villains later that
take the spotlight in the global
zeitgeist but unlike many of them
this man genuinely would have scared me
as a child in a story with such a large
focus on joy adventure and comedy for
this no-nonsense cold-blooded killer
to now act as the main antagonist for
this section was a shock to my system
you feel the tone
shift violently as soon as he takes
control of the narrative introduced to
us primarily through his first task of
killing general blue for his past
failures keep also in mind the fact that
blue has been perhaps the single best
challenge to goku behind roshi and the
fashion with which tao disposes of blue
is as unorthodox as it is
yeah this is someone that wastes no time
in killing his opponent and to add to
his intimidation factor he performs
physical feats
never before seen in the series like for
example he's informed that a jet is
prepared to transport him to corinne
sanctuary
so that he can deal with goku right
there and then however he declines
rips a pillar from the wall throws it
into the air and rides it over the
horizon citing that he'll be back
shortly with everything they requested
in tow
i'd argue that this scene while silly
ought to be i think as iconic as
frieza's floating chair thing
what a visual and what a guy goku vs tao
pai pai
every single molecule of this fight
drives home
one specific message tao is impossibly
powerful
fast and deadly landing thunderously
before goku and his friends the pillar
crashes to the ground and in mere
moments oopa's father is
mercilessly killed there's no time to
even catch our breath or register the
emotions necessary to understand the
horror and tragedy for uppa because
tao like a monster turning his attention
to goku unleashes a
massive strike toward him this is the
first high drama encounter and fight
that there's been in the series
there are no jokes here there's no
levity and there's no ostentatious
flaunting of techniques or poses
this is business and in a few strikes
while easily absorbing goku's absolute
best
fires the kill shot towards goku this
fight felt like a runaway train that out
of nowhere ended in an instant
and i mean that in the best possible way
and as goku lies there motionless i
couldn't help but think about how this
moment might feel in retrospect one
particular element of dragon ball that i
absolutely adored was how routinely our
main character goku would ultimately be
defeated in combat
particularly during the early material
it made for much more interesting fights
bolstered also by the scope of the main
cast
dragon balls are still very much a
struggle to acquire without the aid of
goku
and at this point he's been defeated
both by roshi acting as jackie chun
and now mercenary tao this is a
character that while powerful gifted and
with his intentions honest
still comes up against mountains he has
to humble himself before
and in the face of these encounters we
see what goku
is truly made of speaking from
experience i think one stands to learn a
lot about someone or
in this case a character when they face
devastating defeat
winning does offer plenty of opportunity
for personality identifiers but few
instances in our lives i think
highlight what we're made of better than
a loss and the more devastating the
better goku very nearly died in horrific
death by the lightning-fast hands of
this psychopath
and how did he survive
rooting around for the reason behind his
survival he finds that the four-star
ball blocked the final shot from tau
citing that his grandpa saved him it's a
touching
and beautiful sentiment particularly
when you consider that goku
was given that dragon ball in the first
place for being a good person but the
means with which he survived while
thematically and symbolically gorgeous
at the end of the day only further
served to highlight just how impossibly
lucky goku was
in this exchange for many this would be
enough to push one into reconsidering
their life's direction
surrounded by a terrified child on the
corpse of his father goku is faced with
a scary close call
while holding what he came on this
dangerous adventure for
the four-star ball he secured his goal
and could very easily call it a day here
but to goku none of this matters in fact
i wouldn't even be surprised if none of
this even crossed his mind as a
possibility for the moment he assessed
the situation
goku realizes that there's only one
thing he can do and he jumps to it
[Music]
for those of you that don't know this is
significant because as legend has it
in this chapter if one can climb this
tower they will be trained by a master
capable of vastly improving their
ability and strength and according to
those goku spoke to
no one in recent memory has climbed it
scary for any sane human being sure but
goku continues to climb fearlessly and
as goku begins scaling this ridiculous
structure we're greeted by some more
gorgeous toriyama paneling
showing our hero tirelessly scaled this
thought to be near impossible structure
to climb
forcing us as readers to notice that not
only is goku doing this because he wants
to resurrect up his father but he's also
doing this
in the way that he's supposed to without
the help of kintuou going as far as to
sleep on the side of the tower waking up
with little strength left as the sun
rises
about to reach his limit he sees
something
one aspect of this re-read through the
series that i've noticed has been all of
the elements to dragon ball z that i
liked being present and clearly inspired
from choices made during this material
to some extent
jackie chun vs goku's beam struggle is
clearly a trope that will be used for
years to come
i've mentioned numerous narrative trends
with goku and his allies that will
become more consistent as time moves
forward
and i'm now noticing it more
consistently with korin's sanctuary it's
very clearly operating under the same
narrative principle that snakeway and
king
kai enjoyed think about it a hermit
martial arts master living at the end of
a perilous journey our hero most brave
in order to achieve the strength
possible to defeat evil and protect
others the description works perfectly
for both king kai and korin so
when you look at this thinking about
corn as a prototype king kai character
what was goku's experience like with him
on the tower
well it actually is a little less
straightforward than king kai's unlike
him
korin's teachings are a little more
sneaky a misdirect if you will
tasking goku immediately with drinking
some special water atop a pedestal
it very much becomes a high-stakes game
of keep-away as goku for three days
chases the little catman
all over the tower in an effort to get
his hands on this special water and
while this encounter was brief it
illuminated for me something wonderful
about goku's character yet again
apart from the physical space being kept
between goku and korn himself he
additionally puts goku to the test in
other ways the first is a bit more
direct than the others however he throws
the dragon ball
off the edge forcing goku to have to run
down and back
up but what really impressed me the most
about goku in this scene was
his mental honor and strength most
obviously there's a small interaction
during one of the nights where goku
contemplates and puts himself into the
position to take
the water while corinne sleeps however
despite this opportunity that's
presenting itself just like his refusal
to use kintawun he decides to not take
that chance
but what goku didn't know was that
corrin was conscious the entire time and
acknowledges in his mind his honor being
greater than that of his master roshi
who
also was there opting to achieve the
victory here the right way
and this moment is made all the more
significant as twice before it goku is
made aware of just how daunting this
task is
he's told first at the ground that he's
unlikely to reach the top and once he's
there he's told that roshi took
three years to achieve the same feat the
honesty and confidence one must have in
their own ability to choose not to take
the easy option by stealing it while he
sleeps
says so much more about the character
that any punch kick or beam ever could
this is why goku is where he is today
[Music]
what gives this particular training its
own flavor i think is its dedication to
the mysterious master type format
unlike king kai who was very direct in
his approach the war that korin was
protecting actually has no magical
properties
in fact outside of the one senzu bean
corian gave goku the only reason goku
managed to get stronger in any way was
due to the extensive chase he gave to
corin and his rescaling of the tower
it's very karate kid with corn being mr
miyagi through this
goku manages to multiply his power
according to corin and so
now is time to test what this new power
looks like in combat and arriving in
appropriately dramatic fashion to make
the save on upper
goku touches down on the battlefield and
if you thought the first match with tao
was dominant
this one is 10 times worse tao
barely lands a single attack on goku and
when he does
for the most part it's only because goku
allows him to what i like about this
fight also is the means with which tao
secures his demise
having spent the last while being faced
with the sort of honorable character
goku is when faced with tremendous
pressure
tao is exposed as the slimy cowardly
cheat he is
once he starts to feel any level of
pressure breaking out extra weapons to
even the odds for him ending with him
throwing a grenade of goku
which he easily kicks back into his face
for me the corinne tower and tao pai pai
stuff was by far the most interesting
and entertaining in this arc what
remains in it however is effectively a
few chapters of goku feeling like a god
as he blasts punches and kicks his way
through the remaining forces of the most
evil organization on earth the most
interesting aspect of these final
moments in the red ribbon army hq comes
by way of commander red's mutiny
at the hands of his number two funnily
enough this whole betrayal comes about
because
that red character didn't want to use
the balls for world domination but
instead to increase his height which
funnily enough helped me notice yet
another parallel perhaps between this
and modern dragon ball
in that being effectively the same sort
of wish frieza wanted to make in the
broly film
but at the end of the day when offered a
partnership by the new head of the red
ribbon army
goku without hesitation said no
after all he's been through this massive
ark he's still the same innocent and
honest boy that lived in that small hut
in the forest of mount pauzo
unfortunately however that brings us up
to the end of this video
i love the tao pai pai stuff and i very
much enjoyed the slow shift to more
serious character writing towards the
end of the story and while i've loved
the journey up until this point
from now on we're moving on to some of
the most serious and best written
material in the manga
next time we're jumping back in with
fortune teller baba and another world
tournament i hope you all enjoyed it
consider subscribing if you don't want
to miss the next installment
and i'll see you all next time
[Music]
hey hey
[Music]